two hours later
[Applause]
do you say I'm the prize yeah I'm the
prize I'm the prize I'm the [ __ ] I'm
the prize and when did that happen so I
have a little round to the podcast
really what happened to the podcast yeah
is that all balled up energy bad yeah
I'm the prize some tiny little [ __ ]
said shut up stupid
[ __ ] I got more testosterone in my
[ __ ] than you get up stupid
she knocked his hat off
[Music]
look at the fans see this [ __ ]
yeah she said I'm gonna get some exit
you are doing [ __ ] DJ academics trying
to protect her but you know what if you
looked at this kerfuffle you can't tell
who's the [ __ ] and who not no you can't
same height same weight I mean him in
the business behind him just look like
the same person different week
[Music]
big actions in the building yeah you big
all right
um so just to be clear some people said
he was hitting women or whatever that's
not what happened that was his girl
apparently and there was some kind of
issue in the lobby with the fresh and
fit people all this to say academics he
been acting a fool taking a bunch of
else and I think it's so crazy he's just
Brazen and loud with ladies like I said
before keep that same energy when you in
front of some dudes because I never
heard you yo at an old man in person
like that after we did that video yeah I
had to go back to that interview with
Vic Mansa oh that happened Vic mess what
do you say actually I really think
you're a [ __ ] yeah and what do you just
sit there and say uh
and what in what sense and with this
I I really I really think you're a [ __ ]
because and what was that because
and with this he's been in what sense oh
my God I think you're all what a foreign
you know what's [ __ ] up about it and
why I said the things I said to you is
because where we to be in a room there's
no cameras there's no security you see
us you wouldn't make no jokes would you
make a joke about what no okay give me
this video don't wait for my camera time
he wouldn't make the joke you wouldn't
make we shouldn't make the joke
that was a great interview I saw it back
again and I had memories on live like
people do yo remember that Kevin Hart's
kid where he goes up to his room and he
starts reminisce and all this stuff he's
gonna say to his mom the next time she
talks [ __ ] yeah what do you do hey here
[ __ ] you [ __ ] no that's not it
no hold on hold on hold on now I mean
[ __ ] no that's not now imagine
this is all the [ __ ] that made fun of
academics he got pictures of them on the
wall yeah they're just staring at them
they're like you call me fat edemics
[ __ ] you
no that's not no I got it no I gotta
talk like that girl and [ __ ] you in what
sense
and no I got it yo wait hold on I gotta
call myself
no wait wait [ __ ] [ __ ] hold on [ __ ] I'm
surprised
I'm the prize
okay
I'm a prize
well you look like you surprised
yourself because I did
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I'm the [ __ ] prize
I'm surprised
big
big hat wait don't say that they might
take you fat [ __ ]
these influencers are sus
something smells off
and it ain't waffle fries
it's today's sponsor scentbird
um after you wash yourself you know you
have to wash your booty you have to wash
your beauty and then you have to you
want to smell good in front of people
you want to prolong that good smell well
I got the thing for you scent bird if
you don't know what scentbird is it's a
subscription-based service that allows
you to get monthly fragrances sent to
your door so you can always smell fresh
the uh perfume thing is kind of hard
because you spend a whole lot of money
not knowing what perfume when you're
gonna you want to buy and what perfume
smells good with you sometimes you need
to work out the whole day and you're not
going to spend 250 on that perfume
Sandberg they send you different samples
of perfume per month and then not a
little not little samples that you have
see it comes in a cool little case like
that it locks that's wonderful but all
not only that I can show you the actual
amount of perfume that there is in the
case look at this baby a lot of perfume
for like a month oh this one is good
today they sent me North Atlantic Right
Whale by Sanctuary dark woods and
Mankind Legacy by Kenneth Cole boom look
at this three colors three perfumes
there's even a description in the back
so go down to the link below and use the
code ap2 to get 55 off your first month
at Sanford on us
I'm surprised finish I'm the prize
hey Alonzo Harris and that voice it
don't work
imagine all this stuff all the time you
talk about that girl having a deep voice
why you why why your voice so high
talking like Mickey Mouse up at this
[ __ ]
why you talking [ __ ] about women having
these boys
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah yeah
when I'm sending them showed up
didn't he look like a child lost at the
fair looking for his papa
[Music]
I'll do that again
it's
about who's out here really yelling that
[ __ ] we [ __ ] cornball oh my god
listen listen can we all appreciate
these guys we're trying to lead young
men and telling them all this and how to
run
okay these are the women you rocking
with these ratchet women the ones
fighting in in a hotel in apartment
lobbies with scampi ass dress you could
wear whatever you want but for a high
value men who can get the pick of the
litter it seems like you can't stay away
from trash
interesting
all these options and you can stay away
from the garbageo you was climbing on
The Woman Upstairs talking about you got
a fake titties you got a fake ass have
you seen your girl have you seen the
women you've been bagging
Instagram thought he's even passed
around hundreds of thousands of times
with tattoos and fake everything and I
don't mind I just think it's so
interesting you came at her for that but
the women you [ __ ] all look like that
and if and it's okay let the girl say
you like what you like everybody like
what they like but the fact that you're
clowning a [ __ ] for the same
thing you like
ah I thought I thought I start to see
the pattern here and what happened hey
no you couldn't you you it really start
to sound like
you couldn't get her and she was not
interested
so you try to clown her but you you make
a hundred I'm not saying a hundred
percent but that sounds like mad [ __ ]
let me ask you
do you think it's funny that these guys
who are coaching young men on women
always seem to lose control of all these
situations yeah because I'm gonna be
honest with you a girl I dated could
never act like that with me in public
nor would she never first off I don't
pick trash
second of all I would never kick it with
a girl who got no control over her
emotions or temper like that in public
who would embarrass me that's not gonna
happen
and I don't got it yeah I'm she already
know
a player don't gotta say here play and
if you do that [ __ ] I'm leaving your ass
right now right there and then right
there and then right on the spot you
ain't got to say What's Understood
bars you ain't gotta say What's
Understood do not have to say what's
understanding I have never
ever had to sit here and tell women I'm
that Nick I've never seen Bill Gates
they watch How I move
they'd be around
they see the stuff they already know I
would never think of uttering those
words
I'm the prize who you trying to convince
someone you already got
the only lame Fufu people who gotta do
that [ __ ] are folks who ain't really got
it like that on the inside you may have
the prize on the outside but on the
inside you steal that lean mass nerd
from high school who never grew up and
never really got a sense of confidence
you were cornball that's what you are
because all the players I ever grew up
with never act like this with women if
I'm with a girl unless she my wife if we
just dating and she out here just trying
to fight people have a good night
do you a liability you gotta go after me
you gotta go you out here just starting
fights willy-nilly if I'm not breaking
up with you then I'm breaking up with
you later that night you a liability no
we're going I had a girl try to do that
to me one time no and it wasn't even
that bad I know right on a first date
really we were just walking not the one
I thinking uh that you posted
her
her yeah okay I know that I said
initially because she said something to
some stranger we walking by yeah I said
who are you talking to
and she said uh-huh I said listen and
then if you do that [ __ ] one more time
I'm leaving I'm walking
and we're not gonna argue about it she
took it as a challenge she said really I
said yeah
she's out here in Los Angeles I was
yelling at random people and I said
listen if you can't hold your liquor
you're a liability she said well I'm
gonna do it I said okay but bye and I
just left her and you know what she did
bruh we're in the middle of a
residential area it's about 8 p.m at
night I'm walking away middle of the
street and this girl walks in the middle
screen she's like you're gonna leave
like this like it's training day [ __ ]
Alonzo has it what does she say you
think you're gonna
she took her she did that and you know
what I did like the white boy I just
kept walking so go down to the link
below and use the code ap2 to get 55 off
your first month at semford on us